[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute löse ich nach langer zeit endlich
mein versprechen ein es gibt nämlich die
benjamin blümchen torte aus dem
tiefkühlfach von mir nachdem also heute
eine serie original trifft berlin
ihr habt euch diese torte gewünscht ich
kenne die auch noch aus meiner kindheit
wir hatten dies auch selber zu hause nie
aber ich weiß es noch bei freunden
da hat die mama dann zum geburtstag eben
mal schnell die benjamin blümchen toto
gekauft und dann gab es die einfach zu
diversen geburtstagen ich muss dazu
sagen als kind war ich ziemlich traurig
dass meine mama miti nicht gekauft hat
aber sie hat immer gesagt tiefkühl
kuchen kommt bei mir nicht in frage ich
packte ihn lieber selber und heute packe
ich euch den kuchen der kuchen hat hier
außen eine erdschicht innen eine schoko
schicht und das ganze dann einfach
dekoriert mit konfetti hier ein bisschen
biscuit dazwischen und unten ein
mürbeteig und probiere ich jetzt einmal
ich halte ein tiefkühl kuchen und die
etwa finde ich schmeckt man nicht ganz
so gut raus und deswegen finde ich
sollte dir auf jeden fall von mir das
rezept erfahren wie man eine richtig
leckere erdbeer creme schock tränen zu
bereiten einen saftigen boden und einen
mürbeteig ich stelle den teig den ich
dann später zurecht schneider immer gern
schon am vortag zu und ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten die ihr für den rührteig
benötigt für den teig verwende ich viel
eiweiß eine prise salz 70 gramm zucker
95 g weiche butter 70 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt vier eigene 85
familien und etwas links zuerst schlage
ich das eiweiß mit der prise salz steif
und führte dann ganz langsam sind zucker
dazu jetzt mit die masse angerührt bis
sie wieder schön glänzt und steigt ist
in einer separaten schüssel verrühren
jetzt die weiche butter mit dem
puderzucker
dann kommen dann nacheinander die
eigelbe dazu und dass man den extrakt
[Musik]
und die maßnahme muss richtig schön weiß
cremig sein
[Musik]
jetzt wird noch das mitunter gehoben und
das habe ich jetzt vorhergesagt damit
einfach keine klümpchen entstehen dann
auch die mensch dazu und langsam den
einzelunternehmen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich eine richtig schöne
geschmeidigere masse und die fülle ich
jetzt gleich in meinem back ring ein
den habe ich bereits auf 18 cm
durchmesser eingestellt
[Musik]
und ab in den backofen
nach dem backen löse ich den kuchen
direkt aus der backform heraus und
stürzten auf ein abbildete
so kann er dann abgedeckt über nacht
ruhen und lässt sich am nächsten tag
perfekt durchschneiden den mürbeteig
könnt ihr auch ganz gerne wenn ihr wollt
schon am vortag zubereiten oder direkt
am gleichen tag der mürbeteig ist
wirklich super schnell in der
herstellung und besteht eigentlich aus
nur drei zutaten nämlich einen teil
zucker zwei teilen butter und drei teile
mehl salz und vanille extrakt und die
zutaten gebe ich jetzt einfach in eine
rührschüssel und magnete sie miteinander
[Musik]
bis der teig schon fertig und jetzt kann
ich ihnen zu einer kugel zusammen formen
und dann abgedeckt für eine halbe stunde
kühl stellen oder einfach nur zehn
minuten ins gefrierfach
[Musik]
ich bin ihr den tag so schön flach
drückt damit er immer ganz schön schnell
carlsson
[Musik]
gibt es derzeit gut durch gekühlt und
jetzt kann ich ihnen auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche ausrollen und ich möchte
das auf fünf millimeter dick wird und
nehme daher diese teig hölzer und wieder
schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
da fahre ich einfach einmal mit einer
palette darunter so kann ich den teig
besser anheben dann auf dem
ausgangsstoff aufholen und direkt aufs
blech setzen und diesen tag werde ich
jetzt 20 cm groß ausstechen der muss ein
bisschen größer sein als der rührteig
als laster am besten den bug ring direkt
drumherum
aus dem restlichen teig kann ich später
mal kekse backen oder ihn auch einfach
einfrieren
jetzt nehme ich einfach eine gabel und
kann den teig mehrmals einstechen und es
ist jetzt nicht um den tag zu ärgern
sondern dafür da dass erdmann backen
jetzt nicht hochgeht und schön flach
bleibt und so kann man schon im
vorgeheizten backofen gebacken werden
und anschließend das abnehmen
[Musik]
macht zu bringen
jetzt ist der höhe beträgt auch gebacken
und bereits abgekühlt und die zwei
tortenböden habe ich ja auch schon
geschnitten und damit sie schön flach
werden habe ich bei dem ein und einfach
den deckel weg geschnitten und habe
jetzt richtig schöne saftige kuchen
teige aber ich denke jetzt einfach mal
ab damit ziemlich trocknen und jetzt in
bereits die beiden krems an der reihe in
der mitte des benehmen blümchen uns oder
in die torte haben wir einen schoko kern
und außen rum die leckere erdbeeren für
die erdbeer creme verwende ich 250 gramm
und tiefgefrorene erkennt er mich
bereits auftauen lassen
100 milliliter wasser 20 gramm agha 100
gramm quark 100 grad frischkäse 200
gramm sahne und wann elektra cd- und für
die schokoladencreme 80 gramm peter
schokolade 150 milliliter sahne 100
gramm quark 20 gramm puderzucker und
einen teelöffel seiner fahrt zuerst
bereit ist jetzt die schokocreme zu und
dafür nehme ich jetzt die schokolade und
schmelze sie bei einem warmen wasserbad
das wasserbad sollte am besten nicht
mehr kochen so habt ihr auch nicht die
gefahr dass wasser in die schokolade
kommt und auch dass die schokolade nicht
zu heißen und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal die erdbeer creme
vorbereiten und die aufgetaut und
erdbeeren mit dem wasser probieren
für die sp könnte theoretisch auch
marmelade benutzen so weil es ein
bisschen einfacher
aber wo mit den echten erdbeeren und
schmeckt es ganz einfach viel fruchtiger
und besser noch erdbeeren
[Musik]
wer möchte gibt hier noch ein spritzer
zitronensaft dazu dann werden die
erdbeeren auch nicht braun
jetzt kommt es hier schon in einem
kleinen topf gemeinsam mit dem akg das
ist ein pflanzliches mittel ähnlich wie
gelatine nur eben pflanzlich ganz kurz
klümpchen frei berühren jetzt muss die
masse aufkochen und darf dann zwei
minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
[Musik]
es gebe ich die flüssige schokolade in
eine große schüssel die darf jetzt auch
nicht zu heiß sein einfach nur ein
bisschen warm da kommt jetzt der cvag
dazu anstatt quark könnte jetzt auch
frischkäse zum beispiel benutzen kurz
verrühren
jetzt die sich hier langsam die sahne
woche wichtig ist wirklich nur dass die
schokolade nicht heiße
puderzucker
und mit seiner partei schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich die creme kurz in den
kühlschrank da werdet die schokolade
noch mal fest und die creme wird somit
fester es geht schon ans zusammensetzen
der trauzeuge jetzt ein bisschen
erdbeermarmelade die ist fein püriert
passiert also ohne stückchen fuchs und
die kommt auf den mürbeteig
[Musik]
die schokocreme hier habe ich den strip
beutel gefüllt mit einer lochte hier
vorne
jetzt kann ich die creme sowie bei der
benjamin blümchen torte eben auch in die
mitte spritzen
ihr macht euch jetzt gedanklich einen
kreis und stand die mitte ausfüllen und
noch eine zweite schicht obendrauf
dann ein bisschen glatt streichen gern
auch hier am rand
[Musik]
entweder so frei hand nicht hinbekommt
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch in einen
kleineren tortenring einstellen die
creme einfüllen und den tortenring
wegnehmen
die torte stelle ich jetzt kurz in den
gefrierschrank und kann die app beckham
fertigstellen
jetzt ist auch die erdbeer masse lauwarm
und falls ihr euch mal zu fest wird weil
er zu lange gewartet haben sie schon
fest geworden ist könnte sie einfach auf
dem herd noch mal kurz erhitzen und dann
wieder lauwarm abkühlen lassen
kurz zur seite und kam erst einmal die
sahne steif schlagen und da könnt ihr
entweder das normale sonderfahrt nehmen
oder ihr könnt auch erdbeer sonderfahrt
nehmen und wenn er sagt er hat es auf
kochen mit dem erdbeer mag und so weiter
ist mir zu aufwändig könnt ihr einfach
die creme auch nur mit etwas mut machen
schmeckt wunderbar
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt den quark und
frischkäse dazu doch darüber dass auch
schnell miteinander
[Musik]
und jetzt nochmal electric dazu wann
denn da gibt es etwa roma immer ziemlich
gut
außerdem ist mein lieblings gewirkt erst
dann die sonne unter
[Musik]
also ich glaube die meisten werden
wahrscheinlich zum etwa seiner fahrt
zurückgreifen
das schmeckt forschung richtig lecker so
muss nur sagen ich habe zu spät dran
gedacht
aber egal so habe ich euch auch mal
gezeigt wie man es mit etwa marc macht
jetzt will ich diese creme auch in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen loch töne
[Musik]
jetzt setzt sich umgestaltung wieder
einen tortenring kann jetzt hier erstmal
die freien stellen mit der creme
ausbilden
denn die oberfläche glatt streichen und
wirklich nur soviel erdbeer sahne
dazugeben so dass es auf der höhe der
schoko sahne ist
deckel drauf und sofort mit der
restliche sahne auf den gleisen und
kühlen
und jetzt ist die torte gut durchgeführt
und ich kann sie jetzt aus der form
herauslösen spannend dies jetzt ein
bisschen größer als die originalbilder
mit blümchen tat dies auf ziemlich klein
[Musik]
selbst ich sie erst mal auf die torte
platte
dann den rand ein bisschen glatt
streichen
und wenn euch der webtrekk boden rammt
unten steht könnt ihr da auch gerne noch
ein bisschen creme drauf streichen ich
sind so aber ich ziemlich schön
sie habe ich noch sahnehäubchen
obendrauf die mache ich auch mit sahne
habe ich jetzt einfach noch die
restliche sahne genommen ein bisschen
vanille extrakt und seiner tat und alles
steif geschlagen und setzt jetzt hier
erst einmal die tube und drauf
zu einer rally mitte
und in der mitte ist ja eigentlich der
elefant und dafür könnt ihr euch am
besten eine oblate nehmen opladen kennt
ihr wahrscheinlich aus der
weihnachtsbäckerei
die gibt es nämlich für unter die
plätzchen oder unter makronen und jetzt
legt ihr euch einfach eine folie über
euer handy sucht vorher ein dinge mit
glöckchen foto heraus und könnte es dann
ganz einfach durch pausen und zu mal
nehme ich diese lebensmittel farbstifte
die sind wirklich super weil sie einmal
eine dünne und eine dicke spitze haben
man könnte das schon ausmalen und die
oblate drauflegen und jetzt streue ich
noch ein bisschen konfetti drüber
[Musik]
und der murat da hatten wir gerade
konfetti mitgebracht also streuseln wir
hatten nämlich noch mit der alten
wohnung und er hat mir die ganze tüte
voll gebracht aber kein rosa konfetti
also mache ich jetzt selber rosa
konfetti und dafür nehme ich einfach
weißes konfetti und rosa lebensmittel
sprühfarbe besprüht das ganze basis
trocken und stress dann drüber
[Musik]
morath kommt jetzt auch pünktlich meine
freunde er ist autor
[Musik]
der betrag geschätzt ziemlich knackig
aber wenn die torte einen tag
durchziehen kann
dann ist sie umso feiner natürlich aber
ehrlich sagen ich kenne die tolle nicht
nicht weil das original probieren weil
bei uns daheim gab es ein lieber zu früh
deswegen weiß ich doch glatt
schmuddeliges war gerade auf der
baustelle als gerade mal seht zufließen
gelegt super
na ja wir brauchen gar nicht probiert ja
also ich finds gut
also wer die torte mal selber nach
backen möchte kann gerne mein rezept
dafür nehmen wie vielen stimmen zu
vermutlich wollte ich ehrlich da hat
neulich eine zuschauerin geschrieben
dass es sie nervt das thema das schmeckt
super was ich immer erhalten wie man
sieht also falls ihr die torte nach
machen wollt dann findet ihr das rezept
auch sallys - blog.de
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken und ich hoffe dass euch die
benjamin blümchen torte gefällt oder zum
nächsten mal
was ist den boden rollen immer und es
ist einfach ein schöner mürbeteig
richtig ich habe das hier vor allem kurz
eingefahren
kindergeburtstag feiern mit
[Musik]
wir machen aus
neu bei box jetzt will ich einen kuchen
backen kuchen ohne zucker ohne
industriezucker sally zaubert rus süßes
für kleine naschkatzen
ich habe eine ganz andere tat erfunden
aus datteln so gesund so lecker und es
wird ein regenbogen kuchen und ich hoffe
dass so gut ankommen aber auch süß genug
für diese studie
[Musik]
sonntag 16 uhr bei vox